haha my Foundation is the wrong color
what a treat to me I haven't bought
makeup in God knows how long maybe soon
it is Wednesday and today is an exciting
day we're going to go get an MRI to get
some updated images to see how big and
or small the tumor in my left breast has
become I've gotten one MRI before we
started the whole chemo process and it
went well because I took anti-anxiety
medicine before I went in the tiny
little tube machine and that's exactly
what we're going to do again today paray
for a husband that will drive me to an
MRI while I take my anti-anxiety
medicine and get really chill let's
go so
cute so cute okay we finished the MRI
can you see the lines yep on my face of
where had to lay my face for 45 minutes
basically had to lay on my stomach with
just tits out okay for 45
minutes while listening to headphones of
some distorted pop music this one was a
little tough it was a little bit more
uncomfortable than the last one that I
had done but we did it it is so
stressful cuz if you even breathe wrong
like the whole thing gets it's like
stress meditation this is what um she
likes to do anyone else's dog just like
to sit on the boxes that they haven't
taken out to recycling yet oh life is so
hard life is so hard for the goose hello
I just took a shower this morning go
Birds it is Friday M and I just recorded
an evergreen episode of this might get
weird because I have another round of
chemo coming up on Wednesday and I might
be tired after that so it's just nice to
have secured an episode so I don't have
to worry this I know looks like an open
diaper it's not this is my cold capping
gear that I take with me when I go to my
chemo treatments that thing freezes to
my head so that my hair stays on my head
which it has been this entire time I'm
I'm like so pleasantly surprised by it
it's crazy I'm about to do therapy over
Zoom I go to therapy twice a week which
has been extremely helpful in this
situation I was going to therapy twice a
week before all of this happened so I am
really loaded up on the proc processing
my mental health in real time while I'm
going through breast cancer treatment
which is yay for me great and then after
therapy we're going to go get a mamogram
which is exciting to get some updated
images to see how shrunken the tumor has
gotten possibly it feels like it's not
there anymore so we need these images to
confirm that with these images I can
talk to my doctors about what the next
steps are trying not to get ahead of
myself that's the one thing I've really
learned in this is that like you cannot
get ahead of yourself it forces you to
be in the present sort of even though I
don't feel like I'm in the present last
week was incredibly difficult and so I
think I'm still processing some of the
trauma from last week so I feel a little
dissociated the big thing about cancer
treatment that I've realized
consistently is that like you can't
really think about the future too much
because you have to take it day by day
and step by step I could dream about the
idea that like oh my God I can get a
lumpectomy maybe so soon and then maybe
all of this will be over but that I
can't let myself fantasize too much
about because that might not be what my
doctors want or what's ultimately best
in this situation you just kind of have
to go with the flow which has not been
something I've been good at in my life
and this has really kind of forced me
into that situation of accepting things
on a daily basis as they are which is
very depressing sometimes this week I
think I felt a little bit of extreme
relief that last week got figured out
and I'm on an antibiotic that seems to
be helping but I still don't feel like
100% well so that part feels frustrating
and I feel a little stuck in a body that
still feels a little unreliable that
part is just I think a
huge part of being sick is just managing
being inside of a system that feels
unreliable and not freaking the out
about that so that's just a lot of
feelings a lot of feelings being sick
gives you a lot of feelings let's go
talk to a therapist about all of these
feelings that we're
having let's go get a MOG
gr that's where my boobs
go right on that tray good morning it's
Sunday we're watching Love is Blind and
some football and making pancakes and
someone's ordered himself some
McDonald's happy Sunday hello it's still
Sunday go Birds we're currently watching
them on my laptop and I'm going to make
some tomato soup which is really
exciting I saw this recipe on Instagram
from this woman that I follow that makes
really good delicious looking food and
I've been thinking about it for like 2
weeks and today I'm going to make it
finally it's a no cream creamy tomato
soup perfect let's do it what is this
position football how we watches
Sports oh look at that what a jock first
we're going to cut one onion into chunks
and then I'm going to take some garlic
and cut it up I didn't use as much as
she did cuz sometimes it doesn't agree
with my tummy then we're going to take
about 3 lbs of tomatoes and cut them
into guess what chunks then we take some
basil and we cut it into little ribbons
then we take a big sauce pan we put our
chunks of onions in and we cook them
until they're slightly softer chunks
then we put our garlic in we cooked that
for about a minute until we put in our
chunks of tomatoes all of them and then
our little ribbons of basil and then
about two and 1/2 cups of chicken stock
I think you should refer to her recipe
for the details then half a can of
coconut cream then we add some Italian
seasoning some salt and pepper and you
let that all come together and boil
until the flavors get loud and proud and
then you turn the heat down and you
censor them and yes I did buy myself a
blender specifically for this recipe
this was the best part though I've never
done this before she cut up a bunch of
bread into a bunch of chunks seasoned it
with some olive oil some Italian
seasoning salt and pepper mixed it up
took a baking sheet put down a layer of
shredded cheddar cheese and then put the
chunks of bread on like some delicious
witchcraft the Jets just intercepted a
ball with less than 2 minutes left and
they scored and now they're winning over
the Eagles and I'm stressed out but this
soup smells delicious after a while of
simmering we put the soft chunks of our
soup into our new blender and it went
perfectly I have clearly a natural
ability to adapt to new appliances per
perfect but my God this soup turned out
beautiful the Eagle's lost I'm
devastated the only thing that will
conso me is soup we took our beautiful
witchcraft tray of bread and cheese out
of the oven and I literally could not
wait to put it on top of the soup so I
sacrificed some of my hand feelings oh
my god let's try this soup the Eagles
just lost I'm devastated I got to eat my
feelings look at this oh my God right
that's
amazing M ooh that's so nice and Mild oh
my God I love it oh that's good oh okay
one bird one today we're in the parking
garage we're going to the surgical
doctor appointment this morning I'm in
much better condition than I was the
last time I was here I threw up in their
bathroom and I don't think that's going
to happen today which is thrilling we're
going to go over the images that we took
last week and hopefully get some good
news my stools have been solid yeah
we're back baby here we go help B and
Morgan healthier than
ever hello we're back from from the
doctor's office and we are eating more
soup soup and bread that makes
everything better I feel like I'm in my
own little Olive Garden right now so the
doctor's appointment was okay good news
tumor shrinking amazing it's responding
to treatment really well we are killing
that motherucker nice interesting
curious news the ultrasound that I got
on Friday showed that I have some
Curious calcium deposits behind the
tumor site like closer to my chest wall
so out of precaution we have to go get
them biopsy try to get them biopsy
because they're so close to my chest
wall they don't know if they can
successfully biopsy them until I go
there and they start trying to poke
around I guess so we're in a holding
pattern staying the course we're going
to see how my body responds to this
fourth round of chemo we're hopefully
going to get this biopsy done and get
some information on whether these
curious calcium deposits are fine and
neutral or evil and need to be removed
so it's a strange feeling to be in
you're just sort of like okay that
wasn't the best news but it wasn't
terrible news and it's my own impatience
that like I just want to know when I can
stop treatment when I can get a surgery
and when this will all be over but right
now I can't know that so I have to sit
in
uncertainty once again it's like sitting
in a lazy river full of piss like it's G
uncomfortable but like could be worse I
guess but we're just going to eat our
soup and eat our bread and continue on
with our day because it really wasn't
bad news just some more news my body's
got to get poked a little bit more why
not pile it on Hello Vlog it is Tuesday
at 400 p.m. and we are gathering all of
our things it's an article up on my
laptop about Taylor Swift and Travis
Kelce you can tell I'm preparing to go
over to memories and podcast which is
which is exciting cuz I feel okayish
today enough to go over there in person
and podcast which is like I prefer to do
that if I can because I've taken my
steroids because tomorrow is round four
of chemo so the day before and the day
after chemo you take these steroids they
make you feel lovely they prep you for
infusions they make you feel lovely
after infusions and then you crash but
works out because Tuesday's our
recording day for the podcast so I'm
feeling lovely on a day I'd like to
leave the house so let's get ready and
go podcast by the way I never told you
guys this was M's gift that she got me
for my birthday speaking of tayor and
Travis a Cy Jersey how silly and
wonderful and um if it weren't for the
fact that I recently bought like three
new Eagles sweatshirts I will be wearing
that on Sunday football day what fun I'm
such a jock I've become such a jock as
my body physically crumbles let's go
podcast I've never been caught with a
wedgie that bad I just go up to him I go
I know you saw me picking my wichie chip
said the coast was clear and
he could not stop laughing he like you
could tell he was like are we supposed
to not pretend I didn't see you fisting
yourself morning I'm eating oatmeal very
quickly and then we are off to round
four chemo round four lucky number four
let's do it wo woo a quiet gentle woo
woo from Elliot he's ready we're
it all of our F accessories are here I'm
feeling like a beautiful human cannibal
round floor going well my associate hard
at
work this time around I made myself
chocolate chip banana pancakes and then
Bren with me cuz I'm not looking around
any we are finished round four whoop
hooray it went really well well we met
with the oncologist beforehand they took
out the medication that gives me all the
diarrhea so hopefully this round goes
better we're going to monitor my body
very closely to see how it does in this
recovery reaction time once we see how
it does we'll be able to figure out what
the heck the rest of treatment and
surgery looks like so one day at a time
onwards Elliot any words of wisdom or
thoughts or do you smell anything it
smells like full farts I thought you
farted right before I turned the camera
off look at this oh by the way guys I
mean I just want to normalize and
glamorize cold capping hair because wow
look at this a golden grimmace okay
that's the update I can't stop wearing
my Philadelphia Eagles paraphernalia it
is the day after chemo infusions number
four and I'm feeling pretty good I'm a
little tired but today in a couple hours
we're going to go back in for hydration
and get some shots I think I might have
to get a shot in my butt again but this
time my husband will be there so that's
going to add a layer of is this
weird I have some energy today that I
know will fade over the next couple days
so I'm trying to set myself up for
Success I'm washing my bed sheets I'm
going to make nons spawn but I still get
a ton of hellofresh they do sponsor our
slow cooker chicken and biscuits that I
think I'm going to start to make now and
set it in the slow cooker go to
hydration Come Back N Nom Nom I'm a
genius look at how well I'm handling
everything I just had therapy so I'm in
a good mental health space right now
talked out some good feelings some bad
feelings talked out all the feelings
having all the feelings that's really
important whether you're going through
cancer or not going to cancer and also
um lost my train of thought there it
went uh-oh choo choo left the station no
destination oh and we're going to watch
some reality TV while we cook that is my
happy place I'm going to watch some
people probably my age involved in some
unnecessarily dramatic situations I'm
going to watch them scream at each other
and themselves while I make some
nourishing soup ooh healing we're in
hydration and
this guy definitely has not been playing
a video game he is been reading
diligently and intelligently it's like
you just opened that book to the
beginning Pages not even random pag no
we're getting hydrated it's a thrilling
time so I am going to get a shot in my
butt today and my husband's here now for
layered okay we're back from hydration
we're making the biscuits that are going
to go on our soup Elliot went on a
Target run to get me ingredients to make
make another soup because I'm tripling
down on soups this round and seeing how
that goes for me great hydration session
shout out to nurse Tom gave me a shot in
the butt again also watches the videos
what's up dude thanks for watching the
videos I am tired today I'm going to
make myself some comforting ass soup and
I'm going to sit my ass with my soup on
the couch and
begin round four cocooning cocooning has
be done I realized as I'm in my cocoon
editing this video I didn't really um
end it formally I took a shower that's
so awesome I haven't taken a shower
since Sunday is currently Friday wow
living the dream I'm going to begin my
endless hours of laying down and
watching television but just want to say
thank you for watching this video and
keeping up with this journey it's been
really nice to be able to share this ups
and downs um it helps me process and
helps me feel more present in a
situation that sometimes feels very
surreal thanks for watching guys I will
see you next time I pick up this camera
but for now I'm going to lay down and
probably watch some adults yell at each
other in aggressive and passive
aggressive ways we all heal differently
maybe I'll read a book I don't know oh